>> Sean: THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
THE MOM, WELL, THERE HYPOCRISY
KNOWS NO BOUNDS.
NBC BEING CALLED OUT, TWO VERY
DIFFERENT WEEDS.
ONE PRAISING A PROTEST IN
BROOKLYN WITH NO SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THE OTHER SLIMMING PRESIDENT
TERMS’ PLANNED OKLAHOMA RALLY.
EVEN WEBSITES LIKE MEDIA EIGHT
AND OTHERS ARE TAKING NOTICE
WELL THAT MASSIVE HYPOCRISY.
THERE WAS A REACTION,
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
FIRST OF ALL, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
YOU GET PAID.
YOU ARE WAY UNDERPAID.
NUMBER TWO, I COULD NEVER DO
YOUR JOB.
NUMBER THREE, YOU’RE DOING A
GREAT JOB CONSIDERING THE
CONDITIONS WITH THE MOB.
THOSE TWO TWEETS, WITHIN AN
HOUR?
I THINK IT SPEAKS VOLUMES.
>> LESS THAN AN HOUR AND A HALF.
CBS HAD A RENDITION OF THE SAME
TWEETS AND THIS IS SO INHERENTLY
CONTRADICTORY.
THIS IS HOW MUCH THEY HAVE FROM
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
THEY SEE A MILLION PEOPLE
REGISTERING FOR A RALLY SO THEY
ARE SO CONTRADICTORY, PRAISING
THE CROWD OF PROTESTERS,
CRITICIZING THE MILLION PEOPLE
WHO SIGNED UP FOR A TRUMP RALLY.
WE SAW THIS WITH THE CHURCHES
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP OPENED THE
CHURCHES, SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
THEY CRITICIZE THAT BUT THEN IN
THE SAME BREATH LAW THE PROTESTS
A WEEK LATER.
IT’S SO WRONG.
PEOPLE SEE DIRECTLY THROUGH IT
AND IT’S ALL BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SUCCEEDING.
>> Sean: LET’S GO TO ALL THE
ISSUES, NOW THE PRESIDENT, WE
DIDN’T HAVE ANY REFORMS AFTER
FERGUSON, AFTER BALTIMORE, AFTER
CAMBRIDGE.
THAT WAS ON BARACK AND JOE’S
WATCH.
NOW THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
PUT IN REFORMS.
NO OTHER PRESIDENT, LIKE A LOT
OF ISSUES, HE WILL DO WHAT OTHER
PRESIDENTS COULD NEVER GET DONE.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, LAUSANNE
APPOINTED FOR EVERY --
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE
COUNTRY.
HISTORIC LOWS.
I EXPECT THE RECOVERY.
NOW HE WILL DEAL WITH ISSUES,
MORE TRAINING.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM THE
PRESIDENT?
>> IT’S A BIG DEAL.
WHEN YOU SAY FOR EIGHT YEARS
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
COULDN’T GET IT DONE BUT IT
TAKES A BUSINESSMAN MIGHT
PRESIDENT HIM TO COME IN AND SAY
HOW CAN I DO THIS GREATLY IN A
WAY THAT PROTECTS POLICE
OFFICERS BUT ALSO ISRAEL’S
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE QUESTION LIKE
THIS WILL BE AN INCENTIVE
STRUCTURE FOR POLICE DEPARTMENT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO IMPLEMENT
CORRECT TRAINING SO THAT THINGS
LIKE WHAT WE SAW WITH GEORGE
FLOYD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
THAT TRAGIC KILLING.
AT THE SAME TIME FUNDING OUR
POLICE OFFICERS, BOLSTERING
THEM, NOT DEFUNDING THEM AS A
DESPICABLE CONGRESSWOMAN LIKE
AOC AND ILHAN OMAR HAVE
SUGGESTED WE SHOULD DO.
>> Sean: OKAY, DEFINE,
DISMANTLE, DISSOLVE.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO END WELL.
YOU DON’T NEED TO BE A BRAIN
SURGEON TO SEE THAT.
NOW WE ALSO KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
GOVERNORS REFUSED TO ASK FOR THE
PRESIDENT’S HELP.
THEY HAVE TO ASK FOR THE HELP.
UNLESS IF IT GETS SO BAD THEN
THE PRESIDENT WILL USE THE 1807
INSURRECTION ACT WHICH
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAYS HE
HAS THE RIGHT TO DO.
ONLY IF IT GETS TO THAT POINT.
WE ARE NOT AT THAT POINT IN MY
OPINION BUT WE MIGHT IF THIS
KEEPS GOING ON.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN SEATTLE
IS DESPICABLE.
OVER MY SHOULDER, WHEN THE D.C.
MAYOR, THE LIBERAL D.C. MAYOR
GOT A CHANCE TO CONTROL THE
STREET THAT SHE SUPPOSED TO DO,
THE CHURCH BURNED.
ST. JOHN’S CHURCH BURNED.
OFFICERS GOT INJURED.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME IN AND
SAID ENOUGH IS ENOUGH THE
NATIONAL GUARD IS BEING SURGED
IT WAS A DIFFERENT SCENE IN D.C.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: AND MINNEAPOLIS.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN SEATTLE IS
GROTESQUE.
TAKING OVER SIX BLOCKS OF THE
CITY, DEFUNDING POLICE DUTY AND
ARCTIC GOAL ACTION OF A MOB.